&gt;&gt; Remember, for perpendicular lines, they're negative reciporicals of one
another. So, we're looking for slopes that are y over x, and negative x over y.
While the slope of these two lines are opposite in sign, they're not
reciprocals. I know the reciprocal of 2 is 1 half. So these lines can't be
perpendicular. Parallel lines have the same slope. These aren't the same, so
they're not parallel. It must be neither. For the second pair of lines, we know
that they must be parallel. The slope is 3 in both cases, so b. Here, I do have
opposite reciprocals of one another. The reciprocal of 2 5ths is 5 halves and
the slopes are opposite in sign. I don't know what these lines look like, but I
know that they cross at a 90 degree angle because they're perpendicular. This
last one is really tricky. We need to remember that there is a 1 as the
co-efficient in front of the variables. The reciprocal of 1 or 1 over 1 is still
1. So these are reciprocals of one another and they're opposite in sign so the
lines are perpendicular. If you got some of these wrong, be careful that you
weren't looking at the b or the y intercept. The y intercept doesn't determine
whether or not lines are perpendicular or parallel. It's only the slope, the m.